مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى في دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه الصحفي اشرف ابو عمر نطلع معك
ايضا على الوضع لا سما ان دير
البلح تحديدا ومستشفى شهداء الاقصى كان
محل اشتباكات عنيفه
بالامس نعم حقيقه قبل قليل وصل هنا الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ثلاثه شهداء جراء قصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي في منطقه الزوايده الى
الشمال من مدينه دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه
حيث المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ما زالت حتى هذه
اللحظات تواصل عمليه القصف المدفعي
المتفرق سواء في شرق دير البلح او حتى في
محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى خلال الساعات
الماضيه ولكن القوات الاسرائيليه عادت
عمليه تموضع لها وانسحاب من شارع صلاح
الدين الرئيسي في منطقه المصدر الى مدخل
مخيم المغازي حيث كنا قبل قليل هناك
واكتشفنا مجزره ارتقى من خلالها 10 شهداء
من عائله واحده كانوا يجلسون داخل غرفه في
احد المنازل عندما كانت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه متوغلا في هذه المنطقه وتم
استشهادهم بشكل كامل حتى ان خرجنا من
المنطقه لم تستطع سيارات الاسعاف من
الوصول اليهم لنقلهم هنا الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى بسبب وعوره الطريق والدمار الكبير
في البنيه التحتيه على شارع صلاح الدين او
حتى في منازل المواطنين هناك ونحن
متواجدين على مدخل المغازي شاهدنا ايضا
عدد من الاليات الاسرائيليه المتواجده على
شارع صلاح الدين من مخيم المغازي باتجاه
شمال مخيم المغازي حيث تقوم هذه الاليات
بعمليات تجريف وتنقيب في شارع صلاح الدين
الرئيسي بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك عمليه قصف
مدفعي في المناطق الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي
بالاضافه الى مخيم البريج التي ما زالت
عدد من اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي متواجد
هناك منطقه شرق المصدر حيث تشهد ايضا هذه
المنطقه وهذا المحور اشتباكات مسلحه ما
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه والاليات
والدبابات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
محدوده في المناطق الشرقيه لها ولكن عاودت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه التراجع باتجاه الخط
الفاصل في هذه الاوقات نظرا لان هناك ايضا
حدثت اشتباكات واصوات انفجارات قويه حسب
شهود عيان قالوا بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تصدت للاليات والدبابات التي توغلت في هذه
المنطقه وهذا ما احدث لربما عمليه تراجع
واعاده انتشار في محور شرق دير البلح